je me sentais à nouveau victimisée
comme si elles n'allaient rien faire à ce
sujet, ce qu'elles n'ont pas fait,
elles ont dit que c'était une sorte
d'affaire et ils l'ont fermée,
tant de
femmes disparaissent ou se
présentent assassinées  et puis nous pensons juste
que c'est là une autre statistique
mais non
c'est une personne c'est une
personne autochtone qui
a une famille à rentrer chez elle
qui fait mal
[Musique]
nous faisons tout ce que nous pouvons et montrons
comme hé nous allons
donnez-vous une voix parce que je sais que nous
savons que cela a été réduit au silence, mais non, nous
voulons nous assurer que vous avez une
voix. Des
rapports ont révélé que les femmes autochtones
sont victimes de meurtres environ dix fois
plus que la moyenne nationale
pour le brut.  Je vous emmène dans la
nation navajo où j'ai rencontré Melissa Keats,
c'est une femme navajo de 33 ans qui fait du
patin à roues alignées à travers le pays pour sensibiliser le
public aux femmes autochtones disparues et assassinées,
elle essaie de parcourir 300 miles
[Musique]
je vais juste colorier  ma main
toi  sais qu'au sein des
communautés autochtones, nous
venons d'être réduits au silence pendant longtemps,
la main sur notre bouche
signifie simplement que non, nous allons
être entendus
et nous allons nous battre et faire
tout ce que nous pouvons avec la force que
nous
avons et que nous avons  les ancêtres nous protègent les ancêtres nous
guident
que nous allons faire tout ce qu'il
faut plus de sœurs
volées  je sais que mes pieds
vont me faire mal je sais que je vais
pleurer je sais que je vais me fâcher je sais que je
vais être heureux
maintenant il est temps de prendre la route et de le
faire c'est
vraiment le paradis  ici au milieu de
nulle part le cœur de tout le monde whoa
c'est vraiment cahoteux
dans les années 80 les navajos ont été
déplacés par l'armée américaine c'est ce
qu'on appelle la longue marche les navajos ont
dû marcher près de 300 miles pour aller dans une
réserve aride
au nouveau mexique beaucoup de gens ont perdu leur
vit
c'est pourquoi mel  issa essaie de parcourir 300
miles sur cette route afin qu'elle puisse honorer le
voyage de ses ancêtres et ceux qui ont perdu
la vie
ah
midi le premier jour
comment ça va
j'ai l'impression que caca
tu ne fais qu'un avec la route
tu te demandes quelle était la route que
j'étais genre de  penser au début
comme ça va juste être sur les
miles comme nous devons parcourir nos miles
aujourd'hui nous devons parcourir les miles demain
mais sachez qu'il s'agit de la
prise de conscience
oh
il y a une chute
[Musique]
oh je ne peux pas ressentir  mon pied droit
salut squish
qu'est-ce que tu fais
j'ai besoin d'une douche
oh regarde ça
comment vas-tu aujourd'hui bon un peu
mal
mon achille en fait je ne sais pas si je
peux m'équilibrer sur une jambe mais
assez intense
ouais j'en
ai  différents tons de couleur
ce n'est pas avec du vernis à ongles ouais la
lutte est réelle d'
accord vous êtes tous prêts
faisons ceci faisons ceci
faisons ceci
oh
encore quelques kilomètres nous avons ceci
je pense qu'étant une femme indigène vous
savez
que vous traversez ces obstacles dans la
vie  mais tu vois que tu es  Je vais continuer à
avancer et tu es plus fort.
J'ai en fait été victime de
violence domestique il y a des années.
la mort
et c'est là qu'il a failli me tuer
après coup était en fait la partie la plus
difficile parce
qu'ils ont dit que c'était un genre
d'affaire et ils l'ont fermé
[Musique]
et donc pendant cette période de
violence domestique je me suis appuyé sur mon rouleau  famille derby
et
j'ai réalisé qu'à
partir de là, le patin à roulettes était mon
exutoire comme une thérapie,
vous pouvez être ce que vous voulez être à
ce moment-là et juste
sentir la brise sur votre visage et vous êtes
juste
libre c'est ma petite trousse de médicaments
juste tout cèdre
donc  la racine amère est juste pour se
protéger de tout
mauvais esprit ou mal ou aide à
soulager toute douleur, alors
nous appelons cette peinture de femmes guerrières
et nous la mettons simplement sur notre visage
pour nous protéger, en
particulier en tant que femmes,
donc juste pour nous donner s  trength
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais
vous faites un super boulot
merci oui
[Musique]
je me fiche de ce que quelqu'un pense en ce
moment je suis comme
oh d'
accord
oh mon dieu d'
accord  d'accord,
je vais appeler pour aujourd'hui,
je veux continuer mais je ne peux pas
[Musique]
penser à ce que vous faites
tout en faisant une différence
indigène fort résilient
[Musique]
donc c'est assez excitant nous  '
Je le fais toujours, l'équipe vous encourage toujours
, puis vous allez dans différents endroits
et ils sont comme si nous savions ce que vous
faisiez, merci beaucoup
[Musique]
Nous avons atteint des gens du Canada de la
Nouvelle-Zélande partout  donc je suis comme
ça c'est génial c'est génial
ouais c'est comme un rêve devenu réalité
mais effrayant en même temps
dans
un endroit très spécial pour que
vous puissiez rester connecté avec votre maison
[Musique]
ressentir la douleur sur la route
je suis mince  roi pour moi-même comme c'est ce que
mes ancêtres ont traversé
vous savez à travers la longue marche je n'ai
même pas atteint 300 miles sur mes patins
et vous réalisez
la force et
la
puissance de mes ancêtres nos ancêtres
étaient
et vous pensez wow mon
dieu c'est si joli
[Musique]
merci,
merci à tous d'être ici,
j'apprécie vraiment
et c'est les applaudissements et tout
ça signifie beaucoup parce que nous sommes juste
comme dans un moment de
stress sur nos corps et tout ça et c'est
juste génial  cela signifie vraiment beaucoup
merci ouais
quand vous posez vos pieds sur
terre
et que vous souhaitez ces choses vous priez
pour ces choses dont vous parlez ces
choses ça va dans la terre comme ce
mussolium et ça atteindra quelqu'un d'autre qui est aussi
assis sur la terre
essayant de trouver le chemin du retour
bien qu'il y ait une conscience que
vous défendez vous faites
toujours
quelque chose que beaucoup de gens
perdent espoir
qu'il leur est même difficile de rentrer à la
maison  eux-mêmes ouais alors ouais merci
pour tout ce que tu fais à
chaque pas que tu
fais passe une bonne journée
rapproche les gens
et ça leur rappelle tout comme le
gars qui est passé
nous sommes tous des parents nous sommes tous de la famille
nous sommes  ici
et si nous ralentissons
juste assez nous pourrions voir les
gens qui ont besoin de nous pour les voir
je pourrais pleurer
j'ai été émotif toute cette
semaine
ouais ces larmes guérissent
bien
tu penses à tous
les gens qui sont partis  par ici
qui ont dû
sécuriser leur cœur et s'accrocher à
eux-mêmes pendant si longtemps qu'il est
durci et ils ne savent pas comment pleurer
ou ils n'ont plus assez de larmes
et tout ce que vous faites est de les apporter  retour d'
accord
je pense que c'est le plus que j'ai pleuré cette
semaine
très très émotif
ouais j'ai vraiment vraiment apprécié ça
et j'avais besoin de l'entendre
mon corps est tout
spirituel je priais sur le chemin que vous
connaissez juste pour la fermeture d'
accord je peux '  Je ne dis pas où nous sommes oh
ça y est
[Musique  ]
où est la bande
hé
nouvelle jolie personnelle
c'était incroyable ce que tu as fait
il faut un humain spécial
pour avoir un cœur aussi gros que le tien et des
muscles pour aller avec
ça ne te frappe pas vraiment je pense
parce que la seule chose à laquelle tu penses
c'est comme si
je vais survivre aujourd'hui parce que je suis tellement
fatigué mais ensuite tu vois ça et tu
réalises que
ça vaut le coup
c'est comme un grand sourire juste là avec
comme oh mon dieu c'est intense et puis
comme prêt à mourir
c'est surréaliste
devenir  sur la route était difficile mais nous l'avons fait
et je ne pensais pas que j'allais
finir ce que j'ai fait et établir un
record personnel de 47 milles et demi en une journée
et
je vais l'emporter avec moi pour toujours et le
diffuser  et le dire à mes petits-enfants
un jour, ils ne me croiront probablement pas,
mais chaque fois que
j'ai les journaux pour le montrer
[Musique
] c'est